so I watched the most amazing movie this
week The Matrix Reloaded revolutions
reloaded revolutions is a gripping
potboiler of an action story about a man
trapped by circumstances beyond his
control in a post-apocalyptic future
where robots rule the world and humans
live underground scavenging for supplies
and looking for a way to fight back the
malevolent machines that seek their
annihilation our hero is linked like the
elf from the video game a down-and-out
everyman trying to carve out a better
future for his family in the face of
social pressures a dangerous job and a
crazy boss link works on a hover ship as
its pilot and switchboard operator the
ship is named the Nebuchadnezzar after
the Babylonian king this name is very
appropriate because Nebuchadnezzar went
crazy and lynx boss the captain of the
ship is an insane man whose plans
repeatedly fail and lead to the deaths
of dozens of others but his illusions
are time and again reinforced by
happenstance and luck links bosses bad
decisions already killed links to
brothers-in-law
tank and dozer and links wife Z isn't
too happy that her husband is piloting
the same ship now but she gives him a
lucky charm before he goes she knows he
has to go because he's bound by a
promise that he made to her brothers and
you got to work if you want to get paid
so link spends his days out on Salvage
missions in dangerous territory and
wastes away the free time playing video
games mostly fighting games like Tekken
or Mortal Kombat but sometimes he plays
action games like God of War he's not
too bad at it either eventually his boss
makes a really stupid decision that gets
the ship blown up by some robots it's
kind of sad because now link is
unemployed but he's rescued by another
ship called the hammer that was in the
area trying to stop links boss from
getting more people killed on their way
home they run into yet another ship and
its pilot Niobe and learned that
everything's gone to hell back home the
robots are attacking and they've almost
broken through with these giant robot
drills and there's hundreds of thousands
of robots itching to kill everyone Z is
busy mixing gunpowder and making rockets
in order to do her part commander lock
is desperately trying to mount a defense
against the invading robots captain
Mifune organizes the frontline and this
kid named kid learns the value of hard
work running wheelbarrows of ammunition
the troops so they decide to take a
shortcut in one ship while the hammer
rushes down a tiny service tunnel now
you'll be piloting it like a champ the
robot drills break into the underground
city to be greeted with a massive
gunfire and shooting and explosions and
yelling and yelling and yelling and more
yelling and everyone yelling why is
everyone yelling they're yelling because
the giant drill has legs and it's
standing up but on oh here comes Zee and
her friends with their homemade rockets
to try and shoot the legs out but they
can't because there's tentacle robots
flying all over the place but then Z's
friend manages to blow off the leg but
oh no it's standing up it's adjusting
itself and back on the dock there's
robots flying everywhere screaming and
shooting and kids looking nervous
because this is the first real battle
robots are all like roar we're a giant
ball of robots and they blow up the
control tower and Zee and her friend
sneak behind the drill and she's all dig
this then oh [ __ ] cuz the robot sees
them then oMG run run run but they
escape and the drill falls over and yeah
but another drill falls into the city
and goddammit well the hammer is still
going through the tunnels and robots are
trying to pull it apart and the people
and the turrets are trying to shoot them
all and now it's a good thing that link
played all those video games because
it's just like a game but the robots
knock out the radio in its own Oh then
back in the city Z and her friend do
this totally boss move where si holds
her friends belt and she leans out over
the second drill but a tentacle robot
takes the shot and then they're getting
stabbed at and her friend dies and the
hammer is getting closer but they don't
have radio and commander lock is all
it's a trick that's a mechanical line no
one can fly mechanical but his crew is
like it's the hammer sir and they should
totally let them in and use their EMP to
kill the robots but it take out the
whole dock then this guy's like we've
already lost the dock and so lock is all
open the gate
but the gate won't open because the
robots disabled it and the hammer is
getting closer but the dock looks like
robot hell and peeps are getting their
heads grabbed by robots and the funa is
still yelling and yelling and yelling
and yelling reload then kids running out
there with his wheelbarrow of robots and
dead people and robots well I'm not
gonna let you but my funa is all hell
yeah you're gonna then they're reloading
but the thing gets jammed and a ton of
robots are all imma gonna eat you and my
phone is just like screaming will they
cut him up but before he dies Mifune
tells kids he needs to open the gate and
kids like but I can't
I didn't finish training and my Funes a
badass and says neither did I then he
dies then Robo
that's ripping the hammer apart and
people are dying then kid gets in the
suit and he's all raw sons of [ __ ]
here comes kid and even though he's a
total noob he does a pretty boss job
getting to the gate and then lock is off
you've got two minutes to get that gate
open and Z hears this over the radio and
she totally knows her husband is on the
ship cuz she whispers his name and he
takes over the control chair his kid
lines up the shot but kid gets knocked
over by a robot and he knows he's gonna
die but then lightning shoots the robot
is Z and she's looking badass and it's
all do it kid then kids like I believe
and shoots the chain and the door opens
and the hammer comes smashing through
and crash lands and robots roll Rou did
UFO and Link is a phe fo and emps their
ass and everyone's all yay and yay and
whoa then we wind down Lincoln Z get
back together as tears well up in the
audience's eyes she notices the lucky
charm and he says he's never going to
take it off they hug and kiss the end
best movie ever
the characters are believable they take
risks they make plans they fail
sometimes and many lives are lost but
overall they triumph through with
ingenuity skill quick thinking and
perseverance we feel sad when they die
and happy when they succeed the visuals
are great the pacing is
edge-of-your-seat and the story is
satisfying link starts off doing grunt
work for a crazy man but in the end he
takes control of his life saves everyone
oh and there's a subplot about two
cardboard cutouts who save the world
through luck and coincidence